Hi guys, its Imogen here.
I'm the manager of the exciting Psych2Go magazine.
And with all of your love and ongoing support,
we've managed to just release the 12th edition
of the Psych2Go magazine and I’ve got a
copy of it here to show you.
So, the 12th magazine is on Obsessive-compulsive
Personality Disorder and it's the fourth magazine
in our many series on personality disorders.
The quality of the physical copies is just
really good and the arts and articles are
just amazing.
So here's an example of some of the artwork
in our magazine.
And because we're so excited about this edition
of our magazine, we've decided to give away
digital copies for free.
The link to get your free digital copy is
in the description.
Just go to the digital copy in our store and
input "Issue12" with no spaces at checkout
and you'll get 100% off or if you prefer physical
copies like personally I do, I much prefer
the physical copies of things, you can also
buy them from our store.
As well as our store, we've also got a Patreon
which is how you can pre-order future issues
of the magazine and also how you can support us
so we can pay our staff and also produce these
high quality copies of the magazine.
So, this magazine is 84 pages long and it's
got some of the best articles and the best
artwork out there.
Thanks for listening and I hope you enjoy
your free copy of the Psych2Go magazine.